The rest of this class we're going to be talking about classes, which
are the way we make our own types in Python. The syntax to
define a new type in Python is to use class, followed by
the class name. This is the name you make up, such as web
corpus. And I'll explain what this means in the next unit. For
all the classes in this unit we'll just use object here. And inside
the class there's the block. This is like the block inside a
function, except inside the class, the
block is mostly going to contain definitions, and
they're going to be definitions of functions. We'll talk more about why
that is and what we're using them for. So instead of
using the search engine example in today's classes, I'll leave that
for you to do in the homework. We're going to choose classes
using another example, inspired by one of our students, Andrew who
built a company perfect menu. You can read more about that
in the Udacity Blog, it's quite an inspiring story. And we're
going to think about what we will need to do to represent
restaurants and menus and things like that if we were going to
build a site similar to what Andrew built. So let's assume we
want to build a site to store restaurant menus. That means we
probably need some way to represent restaurants. So we want to make
our own type. So we'll do that by making a class. We'll
call it restaurant. And we will make the base class object. We're
going to talk more about what that means later, but for now that's
going to be something that we put in all of our class definitions.
And for the body of the class we do need something. We'll
just have a doc string. And a doc string is just a string
that comes right after a definition. In this case, right after the
class. It should provide some useful
documentation, so people understand what the object
is. You'll notice that I used an upper case letter for the
name of the type. This is just a convention. And if you have
a long class name with multiple words, you want to use what's
known as Camel case. And this is a many-humped camels, I don't know
if they have camels with that many humps. They're probably a
little unstable. But the idea is to make it so you
can see the separate words using uppercase letters. This is just
a convention, in other contexts in Python we would use underscores to
separate them. But for class names we use uppercase and lowercase
letters. This is all we need to define a new type.
We're defining a type named Restaurant. And we can put that
in a separate file. We'll put that in a file called restaurant.py.
It's not necessary to put classes in their
own modules, but if it's an important class,
which a restaurant probably would be for this
application, it's a good idea to do so.